The Matrix has attacked me he's called
himself the king of toxic masculinity
but now controversial influencer Andrew
Tate has been arrested in Romania here
is everything you need to know
raised in Luton Andrew Tate was a
professional kickboxer he was cast in
Big Brother in 2016 but was ejected from
the house after a video emerged of him
appearing to attack a woman with a belt
something he denies Tate started to gain
notoriety for his controversial and
misogynistic posts on social media once
suggesting women bear some
responsibility for being raped he has
denied holding misogynistic views but
has also described himself as the king
of toxic masculinity his views and the
backlash he faced led to him gaining a
larger audience and adoring supporters
he was eventually banned from Twitter
but this didn't stop him he is allowed
back on the app in November 2022. Tate
was also banned from Facebook Instagram
YouTube and Tick Tock but his content is
still being shared the hashtag Andrew
Tate on Tick Tock has been viewed
billions of times with many worrying
about his influence over young people
online
recently Tate sparked a row with Greta
tunberg on Twitter he sent the climate
activist a picture say he owned 33 cars
and asked for email timberg responded
with a fake email address mocking him
and ending with the words getalife.com
Tate and his brother Tristan have now
been arrested in Romania on suspicion of
human trafficking rape and forming an
organized crime group the brothers have
been under criminal investigation since
April and have previously denied any
wrongdoing
Tate Was Heard saying the Matrix has
attacked me as he was escorted away